>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
WELL, THEY HAVE GOT HIM,
FINALLY.
TRAPS LIKE JOHN DILLINGER
OUTSIDE THE BIOGRAPH FEEDER
BY THE G MEN.
DEMOCRATS NOW STATE THAT
THEY HAVE FINALLY OBTAINED
PROOF, CONCRETE AND
IRREFUTABLE PROOF THAT THE
PRESIDENT IS, IN FACT, A
SECRET RUSSIAN AGENT.
>> THIS PRESIDENT SEEMS TO
BE PUTTING RUSSIA'S INTEREST
AHEAD OF OUR OWN.
>> THE EVIDENCE SUGGESTS
INDEED TRUMP IS, HAS BEEN A
PAWN OF THE RUSSIANS.
>> Tucker: DON HAS IT
NAILED.
AS WE TOLD YOU LAST NIGHT WE
COULD HAVE SEEN THIS COMING.
THE FBI SUSPECTED IT FOR
SOME TIME.
THE BUREAU OPENED A CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION INTO THE
PRESIDENT A YEAR ALLEGE ON
THE GROUNDS THAT NO LOYAL
AMERICAN WOULD FIRE A LEADER
AT IMPRESSIVE AS FBI
DIRECTOR JIM COMEY.
PUTIN MUST HAVE ORDERED IT.
"THE WASHINGTON POST"
CONCURRED WITH THIS AS ONE
OF THAT PAPER'S COLUMNIST
NOTED TRUMP IS ALSO, QUOTE:
ENDORSED POPULISM.
THAT'S RIGHT.
POPULISM.
THAT IS THE STINK OF RUSSIA
ALL OVER IT.
IT SMELLS LIKE VODKA AND
DAY-OLD HERRING.
PEOPLE IN WASHINGTON HAVE
HAD THEIR SUSPICION FOR
YEARS NOW.
BUT NOW WE KNOW FOR CERTAIN
AND WE KNOW BECAUSE OF THE
STUNNING "NEW YORK TIMES"
PIECE TODAY.
IN IT CURRENT AND FORMER
ADMINISTRATION OFFICIALS
SPEAKING, OF COURSE, BEHIND
THE PROTECTED VALE OF
ANONYMITY BECAUSE HONESTLY
YOU DON'T KNOW WHAT THE KGG
OR WHATEVER IT IS CALLED
THESE DAYS IS CAPABLE OF
DOING TO PEOPLE WHO TELL THE
TRUTH THEY NONETHELESS
DIVULGE ON MULTIPLE
OCCASIONS OVER THE LAST YEAR
THE PRESIDENT HAS PRIVATELY
FLOATED THE IDEA OF PULLING
THE UNITED STATES OUT OF
NATO.
LET THAT SINK.
IN LEAVING NATO.
THIS IS A HUGE STORY.
OR WOULD HAVE BEEN A HUGE
STORY IN 1983 WHEN THE
SOVIET UNION STILL EXISTED
AND IT WAS STILL CLEAR WHAT
THE POINT OF NATO WAS.
NATO WAS CREATED TO KEEP THE
SOVIETS FROM INVADING
WESTERN EUROPE AND NATO DID
A VERY GOOD JOB OF THAT ALL
THE WAY UNTIL THE VERY DAY
THE SOVIET UNION COLLAPSED.
THAT WAS THE SUMMER OF 1991.
IT WAS ALMOST 28 YEARS AGO.
VLADIMIR PUTIN RUNS RUSSIA
NOW.
HE DOES NOT PLAN TO INVADE
WESTERN EUROPE.
HE CAN'T.
SO WHY DO WE STILL HAVE
NATO?
WELL, NOBODY REALLY KNOWS.
IN WASHINGTON, YOU ARE
DEFINITELY NOT ALLOWED TO
ASK.
AND THAT'S A SHAME BECAUSE
IT WOULD BE AN INTERESTING
CONVERSATION.
REMAINING IN NATO COMES WITH
SIGNIFICANT OBLIGATIONS.
IN THE 190S OUR LEADERS
DECIDED IT WOULD BE A WISE
IDEA TO PROMISE COUNTRIES
LIKE LATVIA AND ESTONIA WE
WOULD NUCLEAR WEAPONS IF
THEY HAD A PROBLEM WITH
RUSSIA.
WHY DID WE DO THAT?
WHO KNOWS?
POINT IS WE DID THAT ARTICLE
5 OBLIGATES THE UNITED
STATES TO PROTECT ANY NATO
ALLY THAT IS THREATENED.
SO HOW DO WE FEEL ABOUT THAT
NOW?
ARE YOU READY TO LAUNCH A
NUCLEAR WAR OVER LATVIA?
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF SENDING
YOUR KIDS TO DEFEND THE
TERRITORIAL INTEGRITY OF
ESTONIA.
OUR FOREIGN POLICY
ESTABLISHMENT THINKS IT'S
WELL WORTH IT IN FACT, UNDER
OUR CURRENT RULES OF
MEMBERSHIP IN NATO.
ALL OF THIS MIGHT MERIT A
NATIONAL DEBATE.
AT SOME POINT WHEN WE ARE
READY 28 YEARS IN.
NO, THE LEFT ISN'T IN TO
NATIONAL DEBATES ANYMORE.
THEY ARE IN TO SCREAMING AND
THREATS AND CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION AND OTHER
FORMS OF COERCION.
THEY LIKE THINGS THE WAY
THEY ARE IN THIS COUNTRY.
THEY ARE BENEFITING HUGELY
FROM THE STATUS QUO AND THEY
DON'T LIKE BEING CHALLENGED.
THEY CONSIDER ASKING
DIFFICULT QUESTIONS A
CRIMINAL ACT.
JUST THIS MORNING, IN FACT,
THE MOST FAMOUS FORMER
FEDERAL PROSECUTOR IN THE
COUNTRY EXPLAINED THIS VIEW
ON TWITTER HE SAID THIS,
QUOTE:  IF TRUE, TRUMP
SHOULD IMMEDIATELY AND
PUBLICLY STATE HIS APPARENT
WISH TO WITHDRAW FROM NATO
SO HE CAN BE PROMPTLY
IMPEACHED, CONVICTED AND
REMOVED FROM OFFICE.
UNQUOTE.
IN OTHER WORDS, TALKING
ABOUT LEAVING NATO ISN'T
SIMPLY UNWISE, ACCORDING TO
OUR LEADERS, IT'S AN
IMPEACHABLE OFFENSE.
LOT OF FAMOUS AND POWERFUL
PEOPLE IN WASHINGTON THINK
THIS.
WATCH.
>> WITHDRAWING FROM NATO,
EVEN DISCUSSING --
DISCUSSION ABOUT WITHDRAWING
FROM NATO, I THINK, IT WOULD
BE DISASTROUS FOR SECURITY.
>> I THINK THAT ACT WOULD BE
SO DESTRUCTIVE TO OUR
COUNTRY, IT WOULD BE A
GROUND FOR SOME PROFOUND
EFFORT BY OUR PART, WHETHER
IT'S IMPEACHMENT OR THE 25TH
AMENDMENT.
HE CAN'T DO THAT TO THIS
COUNTRY AND I DON'T BELIEVE
THAT HE CAN DO IT WITHOUT
SENATE RATIFICATION.
>> Tucker: DID YOU CATCH
THAT?
THE 25TH AMENDMENT.
IN OTHER WORDS, ACCORDING TO
SAYING MEMBER OF CONGRESS,
SOMEONE THERE RIGHT NOW
RETHINKING MEMBERSHIP IN
NATO ISN'T TREASONOUS, IT IS
PRIMA FACIE EVIDENCE OF
INSANITY.
YOU ARE NOT FIT TO GOVERN IF
YOU SAY THAT YOU PROBABLY
SHOULDN'T DRIVE A CAR IN THE
INTEREST OF PUBLIC SAFETY.
SO WHATEVER HAPPENED TO THE
OLD DEMOCRATIC PARTY?
WHEN DID THE ANTIWAR PEOPLE
BECOME NEOCONS?
WHEN DID IT BECOME THE PARTY
OF CRYSTAL AND BOOT AND
EVERY OTHER HACK TRYING TO
REPLICATE THE IRAQ DISASTER
IN NATIONS AROUND THE WORLD?
WHO KNOWS WHEN THAT
HAPPENED?
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS STOWED.
JUST ASK TULSI GABBARD A
DEMOCRATIC MEMBER OF
CONGRESS NOW RUNNING FOR
PRESIDENT.
ON MOST QUESTIONS SHE IS A
LIBERAL REPRESENTS HAWAII
AFTER ALL OF COURSE SHE IS.
ON THE QUESTION OF SYRIA.
SHE IS SKEPTICAL.
GABBARD ISN'T EAGER TO
OVERTHROW THE ASSAD
GOVERNMENT WHY?
BECAUSE SHE WORRIES ABOUT
WHAT MIGHT COME NEXT.
WHAT MIGHT HAPPEN TO THE
CHRISTIANS AND OTHER
RELIGIOUS MINORITIES WHO
LIVE THERE.
FOR SAYING THAT, FOR HOLDING
THAT POSITION, SHE IS BEING
DENOUNCED TODAY BY THE LEFT
AS A MONSTER.
JUST THIS MORNING THE DAILY
BEAST TRIED TO LINK HER TO
DAVID DUKE, LITERALLY.
THE DUMB PEOPLE ON TV ARE
MAD, TOO.
WATCH THEM.
>> SHE WENT IN 2017, GLORIA,
THIS IS GOING TO BE ANOTHER
ISSUE TO VISIT WITH BASHAR
AL-ASSAD IN SYRIA.
AND THIS TRIP HAS ALREADY
COME BACK TO BITE HER.
SHE DID APOLOGIZE FOR THIS.
>> SHE DID.
HOW MANY APOLOGIES CAN YOU
MAKE FOR BAD JUDGMENT.
NOT ONLY WILL SHE BE
CRITICIZED INSIDE THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY, BUT I
THINK IT MAKES HER LESS
EFFECTIVE CANDIDATE.
I MEAN, YOU KNOW, SHE CAN'T
POSITION HER SUFFICIENTLY
AGAINST TRUMP ABOUT MEETING
WITH DICTATORS WHEN, IN
FACT, SHE HAS DONE IT
HERSELF.
YOU KNOW, I THINK SHE HAS
SOME -- I THINK SHE IS GOING
TO HAVE SOME PROBLEMS.
>> Tucker: THAT'S A NEW
STANDARD IN WASHINGTON, JUST
SO YOU KNOW.
LET'S BE CRYSTAL CLEAR ABOUT
THIS.
YOU ARE NOT ALLOWED TO MEET
WITH FOREIGN DICTATORS.
IT'S IMMORAL.
IN FACT, IT MIGHT BE
TREASON.
IT COULD TRIGGER THE 25TH
AMENDMENT.
UNLESS IT'S, I DON'T KNOW XI
JINPING OF CHINA.
YES THE CHINESE GOVERNMENT
MURDERS OPPONENTS AND PUTS
MUSLIMS IN CONCENTRATION
CAMPS AND YES THEY ARE
LANGUISHING IN THOSE CAMPS
RIGHT NOW.
IT'S NOT A HUGE DEAL TO MEET
WITH THE CHINESE.
THE FORMER GOVERNOR OF
CALIFORNIA JERRY BROWN MET
WITH XI HE PRAISED HIM AS A
LEADER IN THE GLOBAL FIGHT
CLIMATE CHANGE EVEN THOUGH
CHINA IS BY FAR THE WORLD'S
BIGGEST POLLUTER.
WHATEVER.
HE MAY BE A DICTATOR BUT HE